eran tres veces más links en el mismo
tiempo que yo creo que con el viejo
sistema porque yo he estudiado checo más
rápido que ningún idioma en un año ya
puedo leer los periódicos escuchar la
radio hablar y todo es el idioma que
estuviera más rápido de mi vida es no
decir por ejemplo de español o portugués
pero es idioma difícil porque la de este
nuevo sistema es mucho más eficaz para
mí bueno
puede ser que hay otros otras personas
que tienen nuestras maneras otras
habilidades
habituales no para aprender pero
entonces yo voy a normalmente yo voy
solamente a aprender las palabras azules
para empezar
no
y no estoy en esta página
y bueno hacer así así así así el vengo y
cuando todas las palabras
al fin hay ciertas palabras que no
quieres no quiero aprender y lo demás
voy a cambiarnos en palabras de
amarillos y después voy a leer con la
página solamente con palabras azules y
azules y blanco blancas
y después de hacer fresca en todo eso ha
cambiado entonces para contestar a tu
pregunta de roberto es que he cambiado
muchísimo
creéis
de acuerdo a lo que la otra pregunta
a steve en lo de la parte de esta que
dijiste de por ejemplo de los tags que
es cuando viene por decir este temas que
tú quisieras aprender osa por ejemplo si
a mí me gusta la historia de ir a buscar
este no se esté la historia en alemán o
la historia en en holandés por decirlo
así intento es ahí viene que lo estás
si tú lo que tú dices es que en la
biblioteca porque en la biblioteca para
buscar lecciones
si quieres buscar una edición por
ejemplo de la historia en alemán y no
sabes cómo decir historia en alemán
bueno yo creo que si tú no sabes decir
historia en alemán es un poco temprano
para cosas sobre historia obviamente
buscar la palabra pero me normalmente mi
manera de estudiar es que yo voy los
primeros 23 meses puedes estudiar cosas
más aburridas es inevitable al principio
y después de dos meses voy a empezar con
la historia aún hubo otro y en este
momento ya tengo la palabra historia
porque es un pala una palabra que se va
a aprender bastante temprano pero al
principio al principio no voy a estudiar
las cosas para
iniciantes de quien el one tiene las
cosas más sencillas
gracias por responder la pregunta buenas
gracias
y otra pregunta
y no te voy a visitar a méxico por la
primera vez en mi vida
con mi esposa
eres más que bienvenido aquí en méxico
muchas gracias pero yo no he pensado
mucho a méxico pero es un gran país es
un enorme país además vamos a porque
tengo amigos que a canadienses que viven
en san miguel de área de cliente
voy a ser más o menos cinco y seis días
en la ciudad de méxico 56 días en
familia de allende y tengo también
amigos en guanajuato en estos serían
nuestros nuestros bases pero me parece
que de san miguel o de guanajuato hasta
guadalajara no es muy lejos entonces con
el autobús tenemos la intención de
visitarlos
vosotros y bueno vamos a ver y escuchar
mejorar mi español y descubrir países un
poco del país porque ha aprendido que
decíamos visitar no es posible vamos por
qué
méxico no va a desparecer vamos a
visitar muchas veces y esta vez
solamente como tres bases y ver un poco
el en el centro del país y tengo muchas
ganas de encontrar vosotros gracioso
aquí aquí te esperamos ok ok gracias a
todos hasta la muerte